[Applaudissements]
messieurs J'ai dit Messieurs Je hiss le
drapeau de la libération de l'homme aux
femmes je rends leur cadeau empoisonné
serpent et pommees et je veux passer
pour un homme ailleurs qu'au fond de
leur
dodo bientôt ell nous mettront par qu
dans un ministère qu'ell feront pour les
aimer faudra battre le plus fort aura le
ponpon et quand il aura fait merveille
au fond du lit de sa colombe d'un coup
de d la fine
abeille l'enverra au royaume des
ombres messieurs J'ai dit messieurs jese
le drapeau de la libération de l'homme
aux femmes je rends leurs cadeau
empoisonnés serpent et pommes et je veux
passer pour un homme ailleurs qu'au fond
de leur
dodo monsieur ministre avait des dents
qui leur bouffaient le corps et l'âme
elles l'ont élu président parce qu'ils
savaient parler aux femmes mais lors
l'usure du pouvoir a changé son rire en
grimace demain ell pourront plus le
boire monsieur le ministre est à la
cas messieurs J'ai dit Messieurs Je hise
le drapon de la libération de l'homme
aux femmes je rends leur cadeau
empoisonn serpent et pommes et je veux
passer pour un homme ailleurs qu' fond
de leur
c'est un vent qui vient d'Amérique avec
la drogue et les chewingum il y a plus
que les psychanalystes qui passent
encore pour des hommes ils se penchent
sur leur détresse avec des histoires à
la gomme encore un peu et je va
engresse me fairevoir enfin
parom messieurs J'ai dit messieurs jese
le drapeau de la libération de l'homme
aux femmes je rend leur cadeau
empoisonné serpent et pomme et je veux
passer pour un
ur confond
[Musique]
leur